المسيرات وسيله اوكرانيا لنقل الحربي الى
العاصمه الروسيه مره اخرى تطلق اوكرانيا
مسيرات على موسكو حسب السلطات الروسيه
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قالت انها اسقطت
ثلاث مسيرات اوكرانيه وان شخصا اصيب بجروح
نتيجه اصطدام مسيره باحد الابراج ادى
الهجوم الى اغلاق مطار ابن كوفو في موسكو
لبعض الوقت وبغض النظر عن حجم الاضرار
يشكل وصول هذه المسيرات الى وسط العاصمه
الروسيه ازعاجا للكرمنين فموسكو توجد على
بعد نحو 500 كيلومتر من الحدود الاوكرانيه
وقطع مسيرات الاوكرانيه كل هذه المسافه
يطرح اكثر من علامات استفهام وهذا لم يحدث
مره واحده فقد وصلت مسيرات في السابق الى
موسكو بل ان مسيرتين وصلتا الى الكرملين
في مايو الماضي الرئيس الاوكراني علق على
الهجوم بالقول ان الحرب قادمه الى روسيا
تابع قائلا ان الحربه تعود تدريجيا الى
اراضي روسيا الى مراكزها الرمزيه وقواعدها
العسكريه واعتبر ذلك تطورا طبيعيا وعادلا
تماما لا يخلو كلام من تحدي لروسيا التي
اتهمت على لسان وزاره خارجيتها الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها في النيتو بمد كييف
بالمسيره تبقى المسيرات سلاح كييف المفضل
للوصول الى موسكو لتحقيق انجاز معنوي لا
تخفى اهميته وضرب مواقع في شبه جزيره
القرم السلطات الروسيه قالت انها اسقطت 25
مسيره اطلقتها على شبه الجزيره يشير الرقم
الى ان شبه جزيره القرم التي ضمتها روسيا
عام 2014 وتطالب اوكرانيا باسترجاعها تبقى
الهدف الاول للمسيرات الاوكرانيه فقد سبق
ان استهدفت كييف مواقع عسكريه الروسيه في
شبه الجزيره مرات عديده
ايضا المسيرات لضرب مواقع كثيره في
اوكرانيا منها العاصمه لكن الفرق ان الجيش
الروسي يمكنه الوصول الى كل هذه المواقع
باسلحه اخرى اما الجيش الاوكراني
فالمسيرات هي وسيلته الوحيده لضرب مواقع
لا تسعفه امكانياته وظروفه للوصول اليها
بوسائل اخرى